restan pocas horas para el partido y los
fanáticos del fútbol se están alistando
para la final de la champions league
este 28 de mayo en la que el liverpool
se enfrentará al real madrid' en los
suburbios del norte de parís el equipo
inglés buscará cerrar una temporada
notable y además vengar la derrota
sufrida ante el real madrid en la final
del año 2018 los aficionados del club
español confían en una nueva victoria el
real madrid- ya tuvo momentos difíciles
esta temporada a pesar de eso siempre
salimos victoriosos así que aunque el
liverpool tiene un gran equipo creo que
realmente podemos ganar esta copa
de acuerdo con las autoridades francesas
se espera la presencia de hasta 40.000
aficionados del liverpool sin entrada
pero solamente 20.000 fanáticos de cada
club tienen asientos asegurados en el
estadio angola voy a mirar a ver si
puedo conseguir un boleto pero
obviamente no voy a pagar demasiado no
pedimos cuál es el plan si no tienes
boleto buscar un lugar en parís y ver el
partido en la televisión como muchos
otros bots y game el stade france fue
renovado para la ocasión desde españa 24
camiones transportaron el césped que fue
colocado en 48 horas acceso en campo
híbrido es un césped sintético en el que
se ha cultivado hierba natural lo que
permite tener un campo reforzado de
forma natural
originalmente este partido estaba
programado para celebrarse de san
petersburgo pero fue trasladado a parís
luego de que rusia fue apartada del
encuentro por la invasión a ucrania